hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the 1925
Paris tournament it was a double
round-robin featuring five of the very
strong players Alexander - here
Evgeny Alexander is no score borsky
savelist attack over carlo buttinsky and
Edgar Cole and well there were a lot of
very nice games plainly this tournament
but this one is considered to be the the
craziest game that was played there so
it's like I said 1925 capablanca still
reigns supreme
it will be another two years until
Alexander alia him challenges capablanca
for the title but until then we will
check out games well nice games like
like this one here so without further
ado Burroughs as Moscow borovsky opens
the width efore and as the title
suggests Aegean goes for the aliens
defense with nice - f6e five accepting
the aliens defense Knight d5 and now c-4
going for the four pawns attack against
the idea hence defense nice the b6 with
D for D six and now F four so let's see
how alien plays this with the chapters
on e5 early trade in the center F
captures on e5
ending out Knight to c6 putting pressure
on the d4 pawn so why defends with
Bishop the e3 and now continuing
development Bishop to f5 to the most
active square available to the bishop
Knight to f3 and then now comes East six
the bishop has been developed so you can
now close up the pawn structure and
prepare to develop your dark square
Bishop wherever you wherever you you
know prefer with nice to see three and
now in modern chess this is still played
today in 2019 you will see ideas like
Bishop d7 maybe Bishop to g4 but in
those days in the pre engine era you
could try a lot of nasty idea so here I
even goes for Knights the b4 and he's
clearing the path for his c5 pawn he
went for his seat bone he wants to play
c5 but already it comes with the threat
so you can just play a three because the
knight see to check will pick up the
rook so you have to first deal with that
with rook the c1 and now c5 so getting
rid of the the cc7 for making get a c5
pawn of the knight can
with retreat and you are striking in the
center once again
so here a three pushing the night back
and now not allowing Knight to c6 and d5
so I gave him just trades in the center
seek a person before and now a white
good play Bishop character son before
it's not a problem in them then I just
don't undertake you go back with the
knight and the game continues but it
wouldn't be one of the craziest games in
this tournament if you know just the
show character son before was played
here so white goes for Bishop to g5
attacking galleons Queen and he's
basically expecting f6 or Bishop to e7
here would would Bishop to e7 you just
trade characters captures and then the
denied that is under attack goes back
for example Knights the b5 and then you
will well nice to d6 is a threat and all
sorts of ideas are looking very good for
white on the other hand after Bishop to
g5 you could always play f6 and then
you're gonna have something like e
captures G characters and not nice
capture son d4 worth punk after C R pawn
will capture the capture here so for
example captures captures and now again
the game continues but here after Bishop
to g5 I didn't played as something very
different something you might have seen
in the thumbnail it's d captures in c3
so here I can grab the piece and he's
offering his Queen if you don't grab the
Queen you just lost a piece so you might
as well take it Bishop character son d8
was played route captors and e8 at
attacking White Queen and now Queen to
b3 now there's pressure on the Black
Knight here but first seed captures unbe
to with an attack on the rogue black
plays this move he wants the Queen to
come to beat you so he can get this
Knight into the game with the tempo on
the Queen
so Queen captures and b2 Knight to a4
attack night pay for attacking the Queen
and now what do you do with the Queen
it's not all that clear where the Queen
has to go for example if Queen b3 just
Knight c5 is very strong and now if you
capture the night then id3 check opens
up a discovery you will capture Bishop
captures with check you're gonna move
the King or capture or capture the
bishop and then row characters on d3 and
you get this position where black is
just
upon in a better position so you have to
be very careful what do you do here
after Knight to a4 and your queen is
under attack
so Queen to a-1 by Nava Barofsky and now
you could go for some night these three
ideas battalion chooses the
straightforward one Knights to see to
check the Queen and King are now forked
and white will have to give up the rook
so rook captures and c2 Bishop captures
and c2 and now you don't want to allow
something like Knight rook to d1 any
time soon so Knights the d4 blocking the
default from black's rook and also
putting pressure on the bishop on c2
we've pushed back to g6 by ejection and
now c5 a very important move as it
clears the way for white the bishop to
come into the game and what do you do
here well you will grab the night here I
even grabs it with the knight Knight
captures on c5 but it was also possible
to capture it with the bishop it doesn't
matter that white has this Bishop to b5
checked you don't really win a piece
here because after the King moves your
knight is also under attack so here you
have to play something like Knights to
be three because if you go into this
trade for example captures captures now
the other rogue comes into the game the
bishop on e4 is under attack and the
black would just be winning here here
for example you move the Bishop rook e
for check you try and get to the King
over to the D file to get this rook into
the game with tempo and white will have
very little to say about this for
example if King if one just the rook F
for check came back that even you're
gonna go bishop F to check if you're
clicking e2 then the shove h5 check now
you finally force the King you can't go
to f1 just Bishop d4 opens up a
discovery when is the Queen so we have
to go after the default and then the
rook enters the game and now black will
just be able to win this very quickly
so after c5 like I said Bishop captures
on c5 can be played and it seems like a
better idea as you definitely want to
get this Bishop into the game as soon as
possible to either castle or somehow get
the other work into the game but alien
chooses the Dro and Knight captures on
c5 and okay Bishop to b5 check with
Knight to d7 blocking and now Queen to
c3 with a 6 by alien trying to get to
this attacker away from there either
capture on
seven or removed the bishop away so I
can start developing my bishop and get
my other look into the game as well but
shock at first on D seven buys North
Komarovsky rook after sandy seven and
now Queen to c8 check
rook to d8 by and now Queen captures and
b7 basically forcing idea him to capture
on d4 if you don't want to capture on d4
you don't really have other good options
for example you could try Bishop
captures on a3 to try and get your look
into the game as quickly as possible but
then you just get Queen c6 check you
can't go to e7 because of Queen c7
checks followed by Knight the c6 check
you have to go to f8 and then you just
get castles and you have all sorts of
nasty threats here for example Knight
captures here is a thread because the
King is on the same file is the rook and
if you capture it then you get Quinta CA
tracking e7 and you win the rook on h8
so this is the problem if you don't
capture the knife but it's not so easy
to capture the knight here I didn't
captures the knight and then now we have
Quintus e6 check and okay rue goes back
to these seven years to grab the knight
on d4 so that's always always good
always great
and here comes castles and again - has
some problems here although he
definitely has compensation for his
sacrifice Queen but until he gets this
Bishop and this rock into the game it's
it's not a simple idea for example if
just Bishop captures an a3 do you see
what what White has here taking great
advantage of course you do you just
attack the pink piece or rook to d1 and
you have problems here Bishop to c5
check you will not of course see Queen
captures you'll see just pink to f1 and
now there's really no no good move for
for black you're gonna lose this rook on
d7 so here even if you don't capture on
a3 rook to d1 is a pretty big threat so
I Hindus Buddha with Bishop to d3
his plan is okay I'm maneuvering my
Bishop without wasting time as I'm
attacking the rook and f1 and I want to
get this Bishop to b5 to defend my rook
and e7
and now well you could play a song like
this Rudy one Bishop to b5 which is fine
but here no Swarovski finds a very
interesting maneuver rook captures on f7
his idea is of course that if King
captures Queen
chapter Sunday 7 check King has to move
and then you also pick up the bishop and
III and then of course you're just
winning so I didn't rise Bishop to c5
check here now his idea is that if Queen
character see just picks up the rook and
he's just better here so of course you
have to play something else you cannot
capture the Bishop on c5 with King to h1
just getting the King away from there
it's your only move other than capturing
the bishop and now comes Bishop to b5 oh
yeah and here has to decide whether he
wants to go Bishop to b5 save the rook
that way or Bishop to e7 it's also
possible just preventing the attack but
then you get Queen captures on e6 and
after Bishop to g6 pushing the rogue
back rook f1 and you still have problems
developing you cannot get this rook into
the game just rook f8 for example loses
to rook captures an FA the bishop is
pins who have to capture with the King
and then Queen captures here it's Queen
against two bishops white would be
winning here so Allison goes for Bishop
to b5 just pushing the Queen back with
Queen captures on e6 with check rook to
e7 and now rook captures on e7 attacking
the Queen sorry checking the king now
Bishop captures blocking check and now
Queen to c8 check so what do you do here
well your one option is to play King to
f7 but that obviously loses the rook on
h8 your only other option is Bishop to
d8 and this is what a lion played here
we have Queen the ecigs check I gave him
blocks blush of the e7 with Queen to see
a check Bishop to d8 and now Quinta a6
check and it was in this position after
all this craziness and well bloodshed
that aliens loss Khabarovsk e agreed to
a draw because the problem is if after
Queen to e6 check I didn't decide to go
for some other plan other than covering
up with the Bishop Bishop e7 Bishop to
d8
for example if he plays Bishop to f8
well feel free to pause the video and
try to find y alia he decided not to
even try this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding such a well
the only good idea for white in the
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's not Queen a5
check if 25 check then black just goes
King is 7
you could try Queen g5 check King f7 and
then even a 6 check yes you can play
King character as Queen captures and g7
and then rook to e8 and you will have
you know what a lot of points on the
Queen on the King side but after rook e7
the King will hide and this is now still
anyone's game
the king will be able to hide behind all
of the pieces and it's still a bishop
pair in the rook against the Queen so a
lot of things can go wrong if anyone's
better here it's actually black so
that's not the way to do it Queen to a5
check if you found a four on the other
hand then this is most likely a winning
position for white now because you don't
really have a good Square for the bishop
you can't go here you can't go here well
obviously let's check out what happens
if you capture the pawn here if Bishop
captures on a4 then you play Queen to c8
attacking the bishop here and once the
King defends it now you play Queen
captures on a6 with an attack on this
Bishop and finally well again what do
you do with the bishop if there should
be three then you just play a queen
check and pick up the bishop if you go
Bishop the c2 just Queen c6 check picks
up the bishop if you go
Bishop all the way back still not a
problem Queen c6 check followed by Queen
d6 check will pick up the bishop in most
of the lines if not there will be some
nasty ideas with a six so your only
option is to go back but then you get a
six and finally the bishop is trapped
there are no squares left for the bishop
you win the bishop and then it's a queen
against a bishop and rook just just a
winning endgame for white so that's what
happens if after a four you capture it
if you don't capture it if you play
something like brush up to e eight then
the idea is Queen to f5 check King to g8
and now Queen the c8 and you lose one of
the bishops black has nothing nothing
good to play here on the other hand if
after for example a 4 you play something
like Bishop all the way back to e 2 then
it's Queen d6 check you connect the
check with attacking the bishop on d8
Bishop to e7 and now Queen to be a check
and now
just win the rook on h8 king of seven
and Queen captures rook so that's why
after all of these chicks are getting
decided it was best not to go to f8 it
was best just to cover up with the large
squirrel shop if he tried King to f8
chances are that of course Oscar
Borowski who would have played a four
and I would have lost that game but in
the end the game ended in a draw and
alia can finish this tournament I
believe a point and a half ahead of
everyone else without losing a single
game so it was a it was a very nice
tournament victory for Alexander alien
but yeah definitely a crazy game and the
photos of you who maybe never even
thought about playing at his defense
maybe this game will give you some ideas
on why it's such a rich opening and for
those of you who play it maybe it will
be again give you some ideas and on how
to treat certain lines in the opening so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Ellie Martinez
Jason Murray and Nathan buck whizzin for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon checking up on your suggestions
and we will see what else will we have
to do before before the start of the
Isle of Man tournament so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day